[Musik]
es ist uns wichtig straßen buddhismus
klärt kann zu vertraut dass religion und
wo irgendwo zu unterwandern uns genau
wird sondern erlaubt dass irgend geht
eigentlich also wie man sich das sowieso
dass man unter der woche und am sonntag
auch mal tut man da der dreh legierung
zelebrieren und und wahrscheinlich viel
mehr dass das ist ein teil von men ist
also es ist ein wahrlich immer darin
einig also nur lauten ruf und dann
zelebriert und da wieder zur sondern es
ist ein teil von die 10 laufen in paris
mussten und labert das als sehr sehr
intensiv
wie lebt es sich in einem land wie butan
und die regierung ihren bürgern erklärt
hat das bruttosozialprodukt sekundär
viel wichtiger sei es das produkt
produkt zu vermehren
darum geht es in diesem film
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der zürcher architekt peter schmid ist
vor 24 jahren nach bhutan gekommen um
hier im auftrag der helvetas ein
lehrerseminar zu bauen wo sie denn dort
sind sie wie sie sich das vorgestellt
haben schöne stellt wenn es ist so
völlig unberührt und fantasie und wie
gesagt an die hersteller auch die tour
vor ganz gut an die schöne
bautechnologie und verrückt sich dann
die erste was mir auch gedanken über
andere routen und aber sie stand doch
schon einmal hatte ich die butter nicht
traditionelle baute ich nur die verbinde
mit ihrer karriere über sicherheit wie
die neue schulsystem und das ist
versprochen
also ist der geblieben schmid und das
kleine land im himalaya dessen bürger
sich donna drachen nennen
das war sozusagen liebe auf den ersten
blick
[Musik]
und schon bald verliebt er sich auch in
so einem bonmot die er vor 14 jahren
heiratete
[Musik]
sie wohnen in einem kleinen haus in der
hauptstadt thimphu
tag für tag verbringt sondern wangmo
zwei stunden in ihrem privaten kleinen
tempel wo sie opfergaben darbringt und
bietet nichts im leben sei zufall
auch das liebesglück nicht glaubt die
buddhistin sondern karma das heißt alles
sei die folge unserer guten und bösen
taten des jetzigen und der vorherigen
leben
wählen sie eine komische verbindung zu
ihrer man ja natürlich haben wir eine
chemische verbindung in diesem leben
haben wir uns trotz der verschiedenen
voraussetzungen gefunden
mein mann war ledig und kinderlos
ich war geschieden und hatte fünf kinder
aus erster ehe
außerdem sind wir in verschiedenen
kulturen aufgewachsen
es ist nicht einfach aber es
funktioniert weil es wohl so sein musste
er ist jedenfalls immer noch hier
weil die straßenverhältnisse auf prekär
sind ist schmid meist auf dem motorrad
unterwegs zu seinem baustellen
heute ist er einer der gefragtesten
architekten in bhutan ein paar paläste
für mitglieder der königsfamilie tempel
oder in diesem fall ein privathaus uci
natürlich müsse man gut sein um hier
erfolg zu haben sagt schmid aber noch
viel wichtiger sei man müsse die
menschen mögen und bauführer oder
hilfsarbeiter er sei mit allen auf
augenhöhe sie weil man nur durch
baustelle geordnet rufen bei jeder
brauchen dann haben wir die ganze wahl
parteien relativ schlecht weil es wenig
aufpolieren und will als 70 vermissten
shortcuts und darum ist sehr wichtig
dass man einfach noch einen drauf
geschaut und das ist also sobald wir tun
und landrat hat auf sie und sagen okay
es ist manchmal auch das machen wir mal
und dann haben wir sogar die polizei
[Musik]
schmid fühlte sich hier gleich zu hause
eingebürgert wurde er indes erst vor
fünf jahren eine ehre die bis anhin nur
sieben ausländern zuteil wurde
der könig habe ihn zu einer audienz
aufgeboten erinnert er sich um ihm das
dokument persönlich zu überreichen
ja ich bin zum profi geworden und und
mit sind texas 51 sprache und der maler
des viertels tun das ist zwei stunden
und rund seien fantastisch freundlich
und wohne ja wie legal hat er mir das
quartett an trug ein kleid das noch
nicht lange in bhutan einfach die könig
ja das denke ich ist eine gardine del
bosque ein grund mag diese tempel
gewesen sein
schmied hat ihn für punkt dann
anlässlich der weltausstellung im jahr
2000 in hannover gebaut
sein bau wurde als beste gekürt und war
ein magnet für prominente wie jackie der
damalige kronprinz und heutige könig
erntete die lorbeeren und revanchierte
sich
schmieds glück hätte perfekt sein können
er hätte arbeiten wandern und seinem
hobby frönen können aquarelle malen hier
das sogenannte tigers nest ein kloster
das in einen berg gebaut wurde
es zog ihn aber immer wieder weg aus
bhutan für organisationen wie das krk
oder die deetzer reiste er dem unglück
hingegen etwa ins tsunamigebiet in
indonesien
oder in den irak und in den sudan und
dort schulen und spitäler zu bauen
es ist gut etwas dazu beitragen
zu all dem was auf die gewalt und für
mich ist irgendwie ein grußwort und
spannend und identität
bisher ist man sich dass einfache
situation ist vital spa des spitals
bauen als im inland ist ein sehr viel
organisation geht denn was wie begibt
und eine krise gewährt gottes dann recht
schnell will dass es gab dann wirklich
nur um zahlen und das ist sport
gleichzeitig sagt schmid von sich er sei
eigentlich ein familienmensch
seine freie zeit verbringt er am
liebsten mit seiner frau und seinem
enkel der siebenjährige karma
teamleistung ist sein ein und alles hat
sich das alles nur kräuter sie sauber
kirchenchor hand ja ich bin ich bin gar
nicht so offen und meisten sie muss
landschaft und durch unterwegs und weil
ja ich keine familie cabrio ist es
meistens so dass man weiß warum das
andere geld und dann wieder in das land
wir sind schon immer aber nicht alles
haben jetzt bin ich direkt direkt
großvater ja ja ja
[Musik]
dank des ganzen gut für den wilden aber
ein goldschmied der macher ist heute vor
allem im schlepptau fällt mir auf dass
hier ganz normal sagt er mir in bhutan
geben die frauen den ton an
bei einer scheidung geht der ganze
besitzern die frau und auch bei
erbschaft- und bekamen die frauen als
die männer gingen leer aus
und bei richter chef der ja nicht weiter
aufteilen mutter nicht am material holz
absoluter material also offiziell in
bhutan ist es brauche aber ich bin gut
eigentlich halten die schweizer
mentalität
ja
[Musik]
ehrlich gesagt das matriarchat habe ich
mir irgendwie anders vorgestellt
bietet mit ihrem mann sagte hätten die
frauen das sagen
trotzdem schaut er jetzt fernsehen und
sie kommen
er wollte damit vielleicht sagen dass
die frauen alles machen
[Gelächter]
die männer sieht man hier selten in der
küche dass wir das sagen haben bedeutet
wohl einfach dass wir den haushalt
führen hat das sagen in der beziehung
wir sind gleichberechtigt gleich
berichtet wir lassen einander viele
freiheiten was wir verdienen kommt auf
unser gemeinsames konto er investiert
gerne geld in seine motorräder
das ist für mich in ordnung da kann sein
geld so ausgeben bmw ich brauche mein
geld für religiöse dinge gehe auf
pilgerreisen und bringe in den tempeln
opfergaben dar
solche sachen so funktioniert das bringt
freunde sind vorbeigekommen alles bösen
er sei hier angekommen sagt schmid und
im herzen doch immer schweizer geblieben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sonntags treffen sich die männer zum
teil bogenturnier den sudanesischen
nationalsport schmid hat schon ganz
vorne mitgemischt bei den nationalen
meisterschaften die hand einer frau die
dort über mir bei mir war mit macht und
trafen das ist schon deswegen also der
akzeptanz ist sehr groß harmonie seit
zentral das sagt ausgerechnet der
oppositionsführer im
zwei-parteien-system wenn er die
nächsten wahlen gewinnt ist er als
premierminister gesetzt
das brutto glück produkt sei eine idee
des königs gewesen der jetzt nur noch
repräsentative aufgaben habe heute sei
das streben nach allgemeinem glück in
bhutan unbestritten das grundprodukt
drückt aus wie gut es den menschen
wir sind davon überzeugt dass es uns
nicht nur materiell gut gehen muss
sondern auch spirituell und emotional
das alles trägt zu unserer
lebensqualität bei und natürlich müssen
wir auch der umwelt sorge tragen
zusammen essen geselligkeit das sind
hier keine nebensache sondern dinge die
glücklich machen sollen dass heute zwei
mannschaften aus zwei städten
gegeneinander angetreten sind und dass
es am ende einen gewinner gegeben hat
ist eher eine nebensache
und dann sind es einmal mehr die frauen
die im botanischen matriarchat den ton
angeben
[Musik]
frauen spielen hier eine sehr wichtige
rolle wie sie sehen
sie sind total gleichberechtigt es gibt
hier keine institutionalisierten
unterschiede zwischen männern und frauen
[Musik]
trotzdem thompson die ferne schauen zu
aber wenn sie ein turnier machen würden
dann würden wir tanzen heute ist es eben
umgekehrt und die frauen tanzen
[Musik]
ja
schmid führt mich auf die baustelle
eines seiner neuesten projekte hier
entsteht eine entzugs zentrum für drogen
und alkoholabhängige auch in einem land
weil ich es dass pluto glück produkt zur
staatsdoktrin erklärt hat braucht es das
offenbar das ist so schön also nicht
immer nur so wachstum war und du für
wirtschaft und jobs und geld
das heißt natürlich nicht dass das im
bund an was viele viele vorstellen dass
in bhutan im rowdy lachen die ganztags-
und glücklich sind und muss meine die
falten
sie sind zwischen china und in die eine
hand wirtschaftliche probleme an der
abhängigkeit und war es natürlich da ist
viel litschi können wir diesen kurs
studiere ich kann mir das land die tour
aber die ökonomie also die ganze
wirtschaft dauerhaft in butter ist
einiges risikos also die
arbeitslosigkeit und die zahlen das hat
für eine chronik
[Musik]
er wolle mir noch jemanden vorstellen
sagt schmid einen der viel mehr
verstanden habe in bezug aufs glücklich
sein als er selber einen meditations-
meister den er manchmal besucher wenn er
hier vorbeikomme hallo wie geht es dir
bist du glücklich
dann müssen wir doch glücklich seien gut
aber tu mir einen gefallen
bitte werde nicht vor mir erleuchtet
[Gelächter]
absolut happy vom absolutes glück ist
wenn wir nicht mehr leiden die menschen
die uns nahe stehen unsere arbeit ja
sogar unser iphone 6 all das können wir
verlieren wir sollten aufhören diese
dinge als war zu betrachten
die wahrheit ist dass alles in dieser
welt vergänglich ist also auch das glück
dass mit diesen dingen zusammenhängt im
parlament wo das lehrer sind anleitungen
wie wir dorthin kommen wo uns
unvergängliches glück erwartet
wenn wir dieses glück gefunden haben
dann verstehen wir dass es keinen grund
gibt sich über vergängliche dinge zu
sehr zu freuen
gleichzeitig gibt es für einen
buddhisten aber auch keinen grund wegen
vergänglicher dinge in panik zu
verfallen
peking
das relative das vergängliche glück hat
schmid ihr offenbar gefunden aber das
ziel müsste ja mehr sein nämlich das
absolute glück der buddhisten sich aus
dem kreislauf von tod und wiedergeburt
zu befreien
das unvergängliche glück der erleuchtung
ehrlich haben sie verschoben
nein ich habe andere lustig dass ich
rede da die ganz wichtigen heidi haben
im juni galt auch eine ganztags system
aber es ist trotzdem schön und ich es
genießen